So let's take a quick look at where we are so far.
What I first introduced to you is the concept of
snapshots of the RAM,
so you can look into the machine
at any point in time that a polynomial time algorithm executes,
and then you see exactly what state the RAM is at that certain point in time,
so which line of the program it's executing
and also what's in the memory.
I've now also shown you that we can represent
a snapshot as a Boolean formula.
What that means is that I've shown you how to construct a Boolean formula
so that when you have a satisfying assignment
for this Boolean formula and there can be many.
Then you can reconstruct this snapshot from the satisfying assignment.
What we also know is the assignment of the variables
for the first Boolean formula,
so at time point zero,
and the reason why we know that is that
at the beginning, we know what the machine is doing,
because in the memory there's the input,
the algorithm starts at the first line,
and in the memory where we have the output, and intermediate results,
there's nothing in there,
so here, we already know what the variables are going to be.
Now why are we doing all of this?
In the end, what we want to show is if we solve SAT for this
huge Boolean formula that we're building
and we're not done yet,
if we solve SAT for this formula here,
then we want to know what the machine is actually doing
or in other words, what we want to get is
a protocol of what the algorithm here has done.
So each of the Boolean formulas here
represents a snapshot,
but now we need to ensure that they fit together,
because once the machine starts out in this snapshot,
it will move to the next one,
and so we must make sure that if we have an assignment for the variables here
that represent a snapshot,
then the snapshot that is represented here must fit together with one,
so that it's kind of a valid representation of what
the RAM is doing here.
And the way we're going to achieve this is, of course, more Boolean formulas
so that we add to the game,
and to do that, I would like you to think about
some statements for a bit
regarding how snapshots connected to each other.
So what I would like you to tell me is
which of the following statements is true?
The first one is one a deterministic RAM,
if we know what state that machine is in a time point to,
we can clearly state what the state will be at time t plus 1.
The second one is I want you to tell me if
this here were true if instead of a deterministic RAM,
we were talking about a non deterministic RAM.
The third one is a non deterministic RAM
behaves exactly like a deterministic RAM
except when we use the ifbetter function,
and finally, if we use the ifbetter function,
there can be any number of next states,
so not 1, not 2, not 3, but
basically an arbitrarily large number of states,
and we can not make any statement about that.
So which of the following is true?
Please check all of the boxes where the statements are true.